Voiceover:Below are the
steps that Steven used
to correctly solve the
equation six X is equal to
three times X plus four, four X.
Step one is missing.
What could Steven have
written for step one?
So let's see, so this is
the original equation,
they give us a blank for step one,
and then we see that he eventually
gets to three X equals 12.
That he divides both sides by three
and he gets to X equals four.
So the best way I could
think about doing this
is to think, what would I do?
Well if I saw something like this,
my extinct would be to
distribute this three
so that I could start separating the parts
of this expression that have a variable,
that have the X, and the
parts that are constant.
So let's try to distribute
this three and see what we get.
and see if that's a reasonable step for
the direction that Steven went in.
So if we do that, we'd
get six X is equal to,
we haven't changed the left-hand side,
and the right-hand side
three times X is three X.
Then three times four is 12.
So you get six X is
equal to three X plus 12.
Now if I don't even look
at what Steven's doing
right over here, if I'm
trying to solve for X,
what would be the next
thing that I would do?
Well, I'd try to isolate
all of the X's on one side,
and if I want all the
X's on the left-hand side
I would subtract three X from both sides.
So if you subtract three X from both sides
you would then get Steven's
second step right over here.
So this looks like a completely
reasonable first step for Steven.
The first step is he distributes the three
to get this expression,
then he subtracts three X
from both sides to get
three X is equal to 12,
and then he divides both sides by three
to get X is equal to four.